Makaveli anus like a talk a shot but
Sherlock like all this [ __ ] huh yeah
yeah I said we don't want to hear that
weak [ __ ] no money flow China white like
a sheep in the snow I go deep it's the
Bible Hawking debate with the Pope and
you rap let's go downhill like a ski on
the slopes I'll be on the boat with papi
but I ain't trying to copy no work I'm
trying to copy the boat in some more
property
I told Rock we gotta be more than just a
commodity make the house name an entity
to infinity y'all won't be off the juice
no grenadine and stop me from thinking
president you like the scatterbrain sir
Kennedy hat I shot duck down so the
crowd home witness me now can somebody
locate mr. Kershaw and tell he's too big
to blocks away from two shots of being
neighbors with our mighty Lord put your
best material wind and fast for can
trick sign enough you showed your
signatures for Ready Set Radio so my
dude just blessed that Tupac beat that's
what it is all right so the debut album
you say it's about 70% done give or take
are you gonna wait to make the major
move before you put it out or that I'm
really just focused on the music you
know yeah I mean if it I'm banking top
dog and entertainment of course no I
mean that's my mind-state independent
from the jump right now so whatever
happened is there any way you're leaning
as far as label wives right now as far
as who you guys my role with no I'm not
really leaning no I'm trying to stay
distant like my people say just focus on
the music cuz I head it to the front and
top dog take care of business
yeah once I get into the politics of
that type of world is gonna mess up my
creative space any will because I've
been there before
there it is hey I want to happen to uh
before you get up out of here this is
probably my favorite song ever of yours
just uh
Vanity's like - man
as much this is my joint right here um
featuring gucci mane or is it a sample
because i know what sake featuring gucci
mane did he do that for you doesn't
record he deal with J ROC okay okay okay
okay that's what it is that's what it is
I'm smart I know this is the the first
one was on the EP yeah this part too
when all can you tell us about this
record how it came to be I mean your
creative process mmm Vande slays one
woman why wasn't on section 80 yeah
that's the question Vandy slays one you
know that was inspired by a relative
doesn't have himself I said on he want a
big change to spend all his money on
changed and stuff and I felt like that
was a compromise you know from all the
years we never had nothing as black
people and no that's I made Vantage
slade's we all picked him up you know
everybody wants nice things it's just
that when we value to things so much we
start to lose focus on what's really
happening in what we really need
you mean instead of what we want I made
Vandy slaves part two because I thought
it was some dope irony do you know yeah
have a Gucci Mane on it you know and
people trying to make it as a dish no
it's not a dish because at the end of
the day I'm still fighting it to find
myself in and stop from being
advantageously
right here we are the same people we
human beings and um the record came out
dope and that's that's one of the thing
I say when things got to be organic
right since at the end of the day and
that's one of the records that really
made sense I save a nice late part to
looking guilty man why why not on
section 80
um who's debating about that - yeah we
was really debate I mean it fits -
because that's something that represents
yeah innovation exactly where I really
does yeah I don't have a reason why I
didn't put it a minute I just did it was
out for a while - that - dying order
that was mine that was mine too big yeah
you know but the people around me was
like so put about to get into in one
more question have you as have you I
gotta ask about my two favorite rappers
Tanya a nas and he sort of dialogue
between y'all like make us some music
together oh yeah there is some dialogue
happening Oh
both are or each I know one for sure
which one nos no oh man
see NAS and Kendrick collabo come in
that'd be crazy yo we got to make that
happen here we go vanity slave
thank you for coming through my dude yes
sir it's Ready Set ready on i-75